[Applause]
foreign
Ty
honorable members
what an honor to be here with you today
among women
who have blazed the trail for so many
other women
Dr ibadi for decades you have fought for
women's rights in Iran
they try to silence you
they put you in jail
they forced you into Exile but you kept
fighting with bravery day in day out you
are amazing and we thank you for your
leadership
it is outstanding what you've done
today countless women have joined in
your fight
and the whole world stands in awe
of the women of Iran
more and more women are choosing to defy
the prohibitions of a regime
that does not see them as equal
they take off their headscarves
and for this they get beaten up
put in jail even killed
they too are blazing a trail for their
sisters their mothers their daughters
for all the people of Iran
they're claiming not only the freedom
to show their hair
or to cover it
but also the Freedom From Fear
from violence
freedom to study
to work
to love without asking anybody's
permission as it should be it's women
life liberty that's what you stand for
the fight and the courage of Iranian
women move and Inspire women all across
the world
because the challenges we face
may be different
but the rights we strive for
are the same
first and foremost the most basic of All
Rights the right to be free from
violence
this is still a global curse including
here in Europe
and how can you be equal if you're
constantly under threat
there's massive work to do
to change everyone's mindset
to ensure
that it's never Justified to beat a
woman
that it's never Justified to mutilate a
girl's body
that no always means no
and this is why we're pushing hard
to ensure equal protection to all women
in all European countries and I know
honorable members you share my
aspiration
so let us join forces
let us bring to life
the first ever EU law on combating
violence against women and domestic
violence it's time to deliver
[Applause]
honorable members and distinguished
guests
gender equality
does not just happen
even in countries where there is no
morality police
progress is hard one
easily lost
it requires day-to-day attention and
commitment
to ensure that women and girls are free
from violence
that women as well as men can have both
a family and a career
that women earn the same as their male
colleague because they deserve it
that women do reach the very top levels
because they are qualified
we have a duty
to set an example to society and the
economy of what a world of fair chances
looks like
and this Duty counts every day not just
on International women's day
Beyond laws
women and girls also need role models
women who blaze a trail for everyone
else
and that's why I'm so glad to meet you
Captain Christopher
you once said
and I quote
as a child I didn't dream to be the
first Italian women astronaut
I just dreamed to be an astronaut
you just wanted to follow your dreams
and with passion and hard work you made
it
and now girls look up to you
as a role model
thanks to you they know that they too
can aim higher and just like you they
can reach for the stars
Captain christopheretti Dr ibadi
your examples Inspire us
you strive for a world where young girls
and boys can be whatever they want to be
in life
where there are no jobs that are simply
for men or simply for women
where they're not even the sky is a
limit
this is our goal
and again not because women are better
but because we are different
and also very simply because it is right
this is time for World of equal rights
and fair chances not just for women
but for all of us long live Europe
thank you very much
president Wonderland
[Applause]